welcome back to new rock stars moon
knight episode two finally had mark and
steven talking face to face or rather
mirror tamara and we got a fresh new
look at moon knight dressed like he's
ready to go to high school prom or kfc
what are those two things and how hard
is it to keep that suit looking fresh
and white huh you would need to buy a
lot of bleach like a lot of bleach like
god but in like what's conscious laundry
butter anyway like that's that's a
really large bleach budget anyway this
is rogue theory the show where we pitch
the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
going wrong with me today is someone i
would always ride on the back of a
motorcycle with it's jessica clements
what's going on juice
i'm so sorry i just read a tweet on
twitter in response to this episode of
moon night when he's coming down
when concho was coming down the storage
facility and this girl said got that
pete davidson built
oh my god
oh my god does that mean the country has
a big penis is that what that means is i
think that that's what that
big dick
into it
got you now dating kim kardashian
i mean that that would explain um his
powers p davidson's powers i think he
has just has godly powers honestly it
would have caused his power powered by
the avatar for an egyptian deity that
would 100 make sense i would accept it
and of course someone who makes a mean
vegan lentil soup it's whitney van
laningham what's going on whitney i know
a lot i actually do really like vegan
soup it's good it's they're pretty dang
good i do like a good lentil soup i was
a i wasn't a believer at first but i i
dated someone who really loved lentil
soup and i was like all right i'll try
it delicious delicious soup is one of
those things where like you don't know
how good it is until you find a really
good soup it's true it's all about the
soup chef all right no soup for you if
you don't like sushi i was just going to
say
that for you
and of course someone i would always
take a trip to egypt with and host of
the philosopher's podcast it's eddie
villenueva what's going on eddie what is
up guys uh man i would love to go to
egypt i've never been but uh in my mind
let's just imagine it here do a little
reading rainbow kind of thing
just imagination let's all pretend like
we're in egypt together there we go
editors put egypt behind me haha not
live in egypt
not you
all right anyway in this episode
in this but anyway in this week's
episode of moon night we got a new
version of the moon knight character
when steven grant called for the suit
for the first time and this leads us to
our first topic of today
why did steven call the mr knight suit
rather than you know the traditional
moonlight suit because when steven tries
to tap into the moon knight powers
himself it manifests as the mr knight
character in a slick white suit with
some golden beaten sticks which were
pretty damn cool he just pulls them out
like a looney tunes character i love
that so what does this suit
manifestation tell us about steven and
why didn't the normal consu armor come
out for him and why this suit what do
you guys think i was talking to my
friend harry who's a huge moon knight
fan can you hear me
mte did this yeah yeah oh okay oh no i i
have the biggest ear holes in the world
so like my things like my earbuds keep
falling out so i'll do the same thing
every time i do this i'm like i'm i'm a
newscaster like
yeah
hey bob uh
i'm here in the middle of the hurricane
you're in the middle of the hurricane
i'm here in the middle of the hurricane
lost my camera man but we're still
rowing yeah can you hear me i'm the only
person here
lost the camera man but he was only an
intern so we'll be fine oh god oh he's
unpaid he's unpaid he's unpaid let him
let him be um i was like my friend harry
who's a huge moon knight fan because i
was so confused about this and he told
me that this is his theory not mine but
also i was like oh this makes sense that
when stephen turns he manifested the
suit when they said some in a suit he
was like oh i'm gonna take it literally
and summon an actual suit
not his actual like moon knight costume
but stephen also gets the suit that is
just like
stephen gets the suit mark gets the suit
like gets the cape gets everything else
and i think that's so
funny and so great to acknowledge and i
feel like eventually he's gonna be a
good mr knight in that suit and fight
really well but for right now we just
got sloppy
silly
yeah a little learning learning baby ass
uh steven right now but yeah when he
said some in a suit it was an actual
suit yeah i do love oh yeah sorry no i
was just saying i agree with jess like i
feel like the way
uh this particular iteration of whoever
moon knight is whether if he's stephen
graham or mark spector i feel like one
of the best ways that he can kind of
shine while putting on that suit is
essentially put on something that makes
him feel confident like kind of like
when you get a new outfit you know and
you're trying on different things like
for stephen we know he's not very you
know he's not very graceful he's not
very bright at times um but and he's not
very socially adept uh but i mean when
you put on a suit or when ladies when
you put on a nice outfit uh you feel
confident and i feel like this was his
opportunity to kind of feel confident as
a somewhat superhero you know right now
i'm just picturing him getting into a
suit and you guys remember that the
musical episode of how i met your mother
with barney stinson where he's like
you're never fully dressed without a
suit oh yeah just picturing now
moon night doing the little dance and
like this you know the
down the suits in the closet
honestly like i don't i don't know who i
was talking to before but like i think
moon knight is the perfect show for a
little musical sequence at least one at
least one time of the show oh yeah i
would love that so much yeah they should
have they should have removed that out
of the out of the uh hawkeye uh series
and put that music
on this one because i would have much
rather see in this
were
one
fighting himself when he was fighting
himself was the best part keep going
sorry no no i really love this idea of
you know him literally taking the suit
as a suit because what else is he gonna
think he's not gonna think all right
let me imagine this moonlight suit
because like it's sort of yeah it
implies to me honestly i think he's just
panicked like you know like when
somebody's like like somebody's like pop
quizzing you and they're like all right
what's the suit and you're like a
suit and then like he's just wearing
like sweet
a suit that actually does kind of fall
along the same lines as the
caped one it's like it's still white
he's just wearing kind of like a a nice
silk vest
yeah yeah
they're going back to what mt said at
the very opening like
what is country's dry cleaning bill like
and also what is his hotel room budget
like because
holy [ __ ] that suit is crisp it is white
it is pretty true that hotel room had
[ __ ] billowing orange curtains and
like gorgeous like egyptian cotton
sheets and he was like oh i'm drinking a
really old bottle of whiskey because i'm
a fancy man and like well i know stephen
wasn't it was mark whatever i shouldn't
have used the accent but i wanted to
yeah
has like a taste for the finer things in
life it would be interesting to see if
if there's another iteration of this
suit that comes out like because we know
we know stephen is a very you know in
terms of
history and so forth he's very educated
in that aspect so right like what if the
next time he
shows up in the suit it's like a
victorian era suit or even goes back
further and it's like a you know or even
during a time where it's like the u.s
civil war or something because of mark
specter like it would be interesting to
see how far they take that gag in terms
of a suit um i'm really hoping he
doesn't show up in like a maintenance
onesie you know with a name tag that
just says moon knight
that would be really awkward just saying
i'm i'm excited to see what layla's
suit's gonna look like um because
inevitably she's gonna be taken for at
least a day at least an hour at least
two hours if not forever yeah so i'm
interested to see like
they made it such a point to be like oh
other people can be
my like fist of vengeance is what they
saw they called it it's so it's like
okay what did ethan hawk's costume look
like it was everyone's different or was
it definitely just like a different side
of the moon night that we've seen also
our moon night and when i say our moon
i'm talking about mark
main moon night main moon moon night one
his suit is like
it's the like tattoo the tattered like
rags that are wrapped around him whereas
our stevens is so classic that i'm like
how do we differentiate the like how did
you get those two
how did how are you able to choose how
you know when um when uh when they have
those cut that conversation in the
mirror about like you know what what are
you wearing like are you psycho kernels
yeah are you psycho colonel sanders or
something yeah and he does mention that
he was supposed to he was usually wears
the ceremonial robes of pancho so like
that's what that weird robie stuff was
it's like the traditional garb of that
you know the konchu gives it he takes
the robe off the statue and then he
wraps himself in it
yeah perfect so like do you guys think
that because
mark specter that that personality is
more more so down with the whole conscie
thing than you know steve grant is do
you think that that could be why because
stephen greg doesn't so like fully
subscribe to the control belief that he
just is a different type of suit because
like he's just like all right i'm my own
guy i'm not like conscious guy and i'm
me
they're still the same person so it's
like i like he even said at one point
like it's kind of you but it's not you
like it's me yeah and it's like we're
still the same person but full i'm fully
giving myself to cut uh
conscious so i think it's like this is
adjacent to that so it is that you can
get a little further but you can't go
all the way you're not getting the
ceremonial robes you're going to get
whatever i guess you imagine it to be
but it's not going to be exactly what i
have it will never be exactly right i
feel like there i mean there has to be a
sense of belief tied to it
to a certain extent i mean not fully
this isn't peter pan you know you got to
believe and to fly whatever but it's
it's like in a sense i feel like because
of ethan hawke's character arthur
um because of his devout belief
i feel like because of that he's able to
do things like summon those jackals and
things like that and probably more so we
haven't been able to see everything that
he's capable of doing but i feel like a
lot of that is because of his like
devout belief
and i feel like mark spector
kind of has a more
stronger uh stronger grasp on the moon
night the avatar of konchu because of
his belief in that after he's done with
this you know last mission quote unquote
he's out yeah i feel like that has to
tie maybe a little bit into it um
because obviously we've seen steven has
no belief in this whatsoever in fact
he's bought it pretty much three
quarters of both episode one and two um
so i i feel like there has to be maybe a
little bit play in there to where he
doesn't get access to like all the power
but enough to where he can defend
himself to a certain extent real talk
right right right no i definitely
believe that like that's sort of like
what i was trying to get at like what i
was talking before because like yeah i
think that's it's a degree of like
belief that has to be in play here uh
between you know versus mark's belief
versus stephen's belief does
like you don't know what you don't know
right so like steven doesn't know
everything that mark knows he's not
aware of the same things
so how could he
have the same suit if he doesn't have
the same knowledge the same relationship
with consue the same history
right etc
etc but what do you think whitney
i just said that
oh just that i'm sorry
i just was like i just i didn't know if
i got it
no say it again
now say it all again one more time with
me thank you i'm sorry but what else
that was dumb
great one
could you say something better okay
giving you a second
everything you just said we're gonna cut
it out we're gonna remove it let's try
one more time
do you guys think that this like this mr
knight reveal like sort of marks the
beginning of you know us seeing steven
grant slowly adopt this mr knight
personality and like this is what he's
going to wear forever like as steven
when he fights
100. yeah i feel like this would be a
great time yeah i feel like this would
be a good look for steven grant the
person who has the least amount of
confidence so far out of the
personalities that we've seen to come
out as somebody who's looking dapper and
and well-dressed and even with a sense
of confidence because you know we even
got to see that when he's like fighting
the jackal in the streets he's like come
on put up you know he's over here i love
that moment that was a great job
yeah and then he punches and he's like
yeah he's like all super excited
i feel like this is his
like confidence boost this is him
becoming something that he wants to be
as the avatar of konchu as opposed to
just being moon knight he is still moon
knight but he wants to be it on his own
terms and i feel like mr knight is going
to be that for this character yeah i
really do like that like i honestly like
i feel like that's what they're going
for for sure like it's just like it's
all about the personality of the
personality it's like you know if you're
if you're into suits you're gonna be
missed a suit man you know that's just
what's gonna happen
oh sorry i was just gonna say i feel
like this show is just gonna dive deeper
into how how much they can unravel
personalities of personalities and even
enough personalities of those because
this is essentially you know marvel
having a character who has did so it's
like how much can you showcase that in a
in a series while still being tasteful
and exploring that in the marvel
cinematic universe and knowing marvel
they're gonna go as far as they can to
to really create some unique things for
us uh and let's be honest everybody's
been waiting for moon night so they're
gonna have a blast showing us all
aspects within this first season oh
absolutely but like speaking of all
these personalities because we we know
from the comics that jake lockley is a
very popular and very well-known
personality associated with mark spector
so like hey do you guys think we're
going to see jake lockley like at some
point during the season and b do you
think that jake lockley would have his
own different suits like you know
we see that from steve grant and mark
what happened to you there was air in my
capri sun and i was like i'm just gonna
push it out because i'm an idiot and all
the juice came out
oh my god this pouch of liquid i cannot
see this what did i say
oh how dare you mt
how dare you
but no but no seriously like um like so
do you guys think that
do you guys think that jake lockley
would have his own like separate suit
and like what do you guys think that his
suit would look like if he did
we know that he's like a cab driver from
like new york it's just like a silk
white cab hat
with like a sweater vest
not even like like a like a white
flannel shirt and something i would love
that yeah with some white dogs and
everything a white mustard stain from a
white pastrami
i don't worry about it
eating while driving is like hey you
want a bagel he's got white bagels and
everything yeah white bagels only
sure are you like i want to see your
white
ghost yeah and they're like really can
you toast this bagel for me and he's
like absolutely not they have to stay
white we can't not even he grabs the
bagel he grabs bagel and he breaks it
apart and those are his weapons he's
like come on
he's like so the goon is just two halves
of a bagel he's like this isn't even a
knife it's just a day old bagel let's go
that works
that works
yeah just really stale bagels it's just
it's the day old bagel you ever fought a
new york style bagel
oh that really hurts i mean i can still
move but i mean it hurt when you hit me
with your stale bagel
i was thinking though mt i was thinking
lightly i was like what if i don't think
this will happen this is a rogue theory
if jake lockley was the person that
conscious was referring to as in like
because mark keeps being or stephen
keeps saying like it's gonna be layla
he's gonna take leila he's gonna take
layla for me what if he's like there's
another person you don't know yet that's
deep down inside of you that's jake and
i'm taking that mother like you thought
it was you
you thought it was layla but it was
actually another version of yourself so
i'm still going to be controlling you
you're not going to be happy with the
outcome it's someone that's close and
dear to you it's yourself but it's jake
yeah um yeah i don't know if that would
happen but i was like that would be
con and that i'm glad it's like starting
to be recognized i love his little like
little like petty two-year-old like
knocking over thing yes
i love it the roast of cod she was so so
delightful when he straight up emperor
palpatine and said
[Laughter]
yeah dude shut up he's like
he's telling you to kill me isn't he
he's like yeah it was like he said
he was standing at the top and he said i
am justice he's like
he's [ __ ] like a child that thinks
they're batman
[Laughter]
so you guys feel like jake lockley could
come up later this season oh yeah
i i feel like if it's gonna be anything
they're to do like a reveal towards the
tail end of the series
yeah
because i think right now just getting
to know mark spector and
you know steven grant is going to be a
handful enough as it is uh with the
added fact that konchu is in the mix so
i i feel like we're going to get a lot
more time spent with those two before we
move over to any of the other
personalities
um personally nice no i i definitely
feel the same way like it's just like
you're pacing themselves marvel likes to
pace themselves a little bit so like
there's no reason to go full steam if
you could just like tell the story in a
nice calm way so i think that's the way
to go but no i loved all these theories
especially the bagel stuff i think that
we're gonna see some bagel action um i
really want to see the moon i go random
[ __ ] go like the media yeah oh my
gosh
i saw that comic channel and you tweeted
and it's perfect that's also all i want
these are all great theories i want to
give whitney and just 5 000 points each
for their theories but
mr mr friend over here mr eddie you're
about to get 6 000 for your idea of like
this idea of like his like belief being
part of
what's happening with this suit and like
what's what's happening with mark
spector because like there's also a huge
difference of belief between mark and
steven so that has to be a factor there
at least in my humble weird opinion but
anyway bagel knives
and
that's also going to be a factor that's
playing it
that's how steven's going down sorry
that's how arthur harrow's going down do
carbs
death by carbs
he's getting anyways
he's like no no don't do it gluten's my
my biggest weakness um but up next we
are going to talk about the next
potential fist of konchu but first if
you like what we do at new rockstars and
you also like cool nerdy t-shirts well
i've got some great news for you there's
something you can do that checks off
both of those boxes if you could buy the
boom night's latest obsession shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com and this shirt is
called tomb of the moon god it's a very
cool design and buying it directly
supports new rockstars and all the
content that we make it's literally the
best way to support us and every shirt
bot adds a little easter egg to a future
breakdown which is very cool we also
want to thank upstart for sponsoring
this video because we've all been hit by
an unexpected extreme expense or bill
and it's like getting t-boned by a
semi-truck a financial stress but
luckily upstart is here to help upstart
powered personal loans can help you pay
down high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers with paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses and upstart
can help you get one fixed monthly
payment with a clear payoff date upstart
knows that you are more than just your
credit score so upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application define
you a smarter rate for your loan and you
can check your rate in minutes for loans
between 1 000 to 50 000 without
impacting your credit score and you can
even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
so don't wait and check your rate today
at upstart.com
rogue theory that's upstart.com
rogue theory to check your rate today
and don't forget to use our url to let
them know that we send you okay that's
very important and loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application so please go to
upstart.com
rogue theory it can be tough to dress
during the spring when the weather can
shift wildly from day to day luckily
faraday makes it way easier they make
the perfect clothing for all seasons
parody is a family-run brand making
high-quality timeless clothing with
modern design and functionality and all
their clothing has an effortless style
that works no matter what you're doing
heading to work going out with friends
pitching a mark spectre theory parody
works for all of that and around the new
rockstar's office everyone loves it when
a faraday delivery comes we all hold
hands and sing kumbaya they're the
prized possessions of everyone's
wardrobe and the pharisees so confident
in the quality of their stuff that they
have a lifetime guarantee of quality
which means that they will replace or
fix your clothes forever no matter what
which is a pretty good deal that's like
a really that's a binding contract jeez
do you really wanna make that promise um
to talk about making it easier to get
dressed and right now verity is giving
the rogue theory audience 20 off that's
20 percent off if you go to
heritybrand.com rogue and use the code
world at checkout to snag 20 off all of
your new spring staples that is code
rogue r o g u e farady f a h e r t y
brand dot com slash rogue for 20 off
veritybrand.com
slash rogue don't you forget it don't
forget about verity all don't you do it
but anyway you guys ready for top of two
that's right yeah but now i'm
disappointed that we don't all sing a
little song when the mail
[Music]
that's
i'm a big singing when the male arrives
kind of person yeah i'm traumatized from
singing from the last 10 years we talked
about that before going on here just
saying
oh yeah
i know i'm sorry i have like the worst
memory in the world i'm like super
tired didn't you bless people here we go
anyway [ __ ]
sorry keep going
all right guys because another thing we
learned in this episode this week is
that there have been many avatars of
konchu over the years and one way that
konchu keeps his current avatar in check
is by threatening them to move on to his
next one blackmail from god not great
but that's usually how religion works
but anyway this leads us to our second
topic for today why does konchu want
leila as his next avatar because we hear
kanchu threaten mark with the prospect
of taking on leila as his next avatar
something that mark does not want to
happen so is this just a threat from
kanchu to keep mark in line or is there
something about leila that makes her the
perfect avatar in conscious um
lack of eyes
of where the hole that
his eyes would be promising
i feel like okay because i wanted to
throw this out because i don't know if
anyone's going to take it to be honest
um so
a couple years back there was a there
was a series called acts of evil it was
a uh it was a mini event several
different volumes different uh
characters moon knight had an annual out
of that whole series
um in that series it was essentially
where
uh each marvel character or certain
marvel characters were going to be
facing against other heroes as uh super
villains and in this one he was fighting
against kang the conqueror
um so in this one uh because of their
battle they end up going through time
and essentially moon knight visits with
every single iteration of moon knight
over the years from like the victorian
era all that until he gets to the very
beginning
and he finds that at the very beginning
the very first moon knight
was a priestess of konchu
and so
my thought is what if layla what if
konchu knows that laila is the
reincarnation of the first moon knight
as a priestess of konchu and that's why
he has his eye set on her instead of him
like you know oh yeah you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna take her i'm gonna take your
mom i'm gonna take this with like any of
these other people he's focusing on
layla because he knows i mean we're
talking about egyptian culture we're
talking about
history you know there's a strong belief
of reincarnation within the egyptian
culture back then so what if this entire
time
kanchu knows that laila is the
reincarnation of the priestess of konchu
and that's why he's so focused he
already knows no matter what even if
mark spector does this last mission he
knows that he has an ace in the hole
with layla if mark decides to you know
act a fool and take off interesting i
really like that
i would really dig that because like i i
didn't personally know that about the
first ever moonlight it's a great series
the acts of evil it was just a one-year
event but it had like wolverine yeah
that sounds really bad oh yes it's
really cool yeah so 2019 came out in
2019.
interesting so leila has secret special
blood that makes her the best moon eyed
of all possibly the moon queen possibly
no i'm starting over i'm getting me a
bad [ __ ] for my avatar
eddie's answer is way cooler
i would love to for country to say the
sentence
mark why aren't you a bad [ __ ] like
leila
you're making me do this mark you're
making me mm-hmm
[Laughter]
no i really dig that idea that hawk is
like what is he saying to you now i'm a
hot [ __ ] oh don't worry about it [ __ ]
i'm wearing a hot [ __ ] in charge don't
worry about it
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
that's what he does when he's not around
he's just watching megan
she's just like i'm doing hot girl [ __ ]
he's got what we're playing in the
background and everything yeah don't
look at him
oh my god
what do you guys think um
uh
yeah i agree with um whitney mine is not
as good as eddie's uh mine was actually
originally don't say that so maybe i
should get the point because that was
really what i was going to say no uh
i i yeah yeah
um
yeah i don't really have anything now
i'm sorry
i mean okay
i mean there's also the opportunity of
you know
layla kind of playing you know because i
always thought i thought of another one
because way back when moon night first
started uh there was also
uh in one of the earlier issues i think
like issue number 42 or something it was
way back when um moon knight actually
finds an evil doppelganger of himself
named moonshade
and
what if this entire time like
con what if kanchu is already working
with layla
oh yeah that could be is
you know and so he's already got
like a part of his powers is they're
already in her
and she's working on that end to where
if mark spector starts moving towards
the being a little bit more morally
right because it looks like his past is
a little morally gray uh with all the
things that he was shown and everything
what if she's the one who has no problem
being
morally ambiguous in doing whatever
kancho needs and so at that time when
mark spector decides to
kind of be mr right
she's there to automatically put on the
robes she has the power and she's going
to be his counterpart to fight against
at that last part of the series
as like moon shade what if layla is just
passed
what if layla is actually a god and
that's why you couldn't colonize her
mind so she he decided to colonize her
fiances which is mark
uh there you go that's my theory the
great thing about this is layla is a
complete original character
there isn't a layla yeah comics so it's
yeah
it's ultimately up to marvel's
interpretation of how they want that
character to go
um through whatever vein that's either
already established or through a vein
that they're going to create all on
their own like we could all be wrong and
she's like actually the egyptian
daredevil and she's like whatever it
could be anything to that effect marvel
can do whatever they want but right from
you know what we know and the
opportunities that are already created i
mean
there's a lot of opportunities to see
her become that badass that we want her
to be and we know she can be so it'll be
interesting
but those are my two theories i'm glad
that eddie is just running laps in
theories around us
we're just like because leila is cool
because she's the one
two or three amazing actual reasons that
are real and not just you and just
[ __ ] around she's biracial so i think
she's a bi-racial queen a queen god
there you go there you go i'll take it
yeah
but uh no because like i think it's
really interesting to see that like
with with this layla character in
because we know in the moonlight comics
mark spector's girlfriend is this woman
named marlene and she was the son the
daughter of an archaeologist and they
that's how they sort of met when he
before he became moon knight so like do
you think that layla could secretly be a
marlene who doesn't remember that she's
marlene i think i could be true but i
think they also just wanted
not to be
that person
but i think they were like there's a lot
of white faces in this egyptian rand
show and marlene is blonde white and so
i think they probably are
maybe it's good if we tried to like make
a new love interest uh one that is also
an enthusiast in like egyptian culture
but also is brown uh
the great thing is the great thing is
about this we have yet to hear her
maiden last name
that is also true so yeah she could she
could share that she could still be the
layla character just with
you know layla instead of marlene and
her maiden name be the same as marlene's
made whatever marlene is her mom or
something
like marlene
or something like that what if marlene's
just her middle name yeah
listen to me and wendy's theories don't
listen to eddie's so what if she
actually works we are
at the bodega on the corner she sells
sandwiches to crowley who is the golden
statue man right hear me out there you
go yes her name is layla crowley she's
she's her uh white she's his wife
um i don't know what i'm saying
oh but no i yes the statue she's married
to the statue
i hope the statue man ends up saving the
day at the end of this i hope like
randomly
he's gonna come to you
i'm waiting
this series is going to do what a hot
tub time machine did when uh they were
waiting for that guy to lose his arm and
it was like everybody's like oh like i'm
waiting to see if he's going to move
from that seat or talk like every
episode i'm going to see him like say
something you bastard
i just want the first definitive f word
to come from this man to be like shut
the [ __ ] up steve shut up
you're not the only one with problems
okay
i want him to walk away with a whistle
in his mouth
[Applause]
it just goes
[Laughter]
i love this idea of like going back to
the very beginnings of the moon knight
origin to find the first um first ever
moon night because i just watched
turning red last night and they sort of
did that with the whole panda like we
thought the original panda ladies are
like i'm all about it let's go back to
the original
huh what did you say we did did you
catch that he said let's find the
original vandalism did he say find or oh
fine
no no no no i didn't say oh no no no no
no
the only dirty things in that movie are
under that girl's bed in her drawings uh
[Laughter]
um but no i'm going to give once again
i'm going to give eddie
five thousand points here for his answer
because thank you
this idea because like i know that you
said that because she's cool but like i
think that that's actually there's
there's merits to that because like she
is a kind of like a lot more relentless
than steve is that she doesn't have like
steve's problems she doesn't have market
problems so like she could just because
she should be like you know what why
don't i just use this girl like why is
[ __ ] around why he can't he's like
too much trouble stephen is high
maintenance
we're trying we think it's like easy
what khanshu is doing but it must be so
hard to colonize the mind of a human
being especially a mind of layla who is
like
like
i don't have these like i don't have
these
fears i don't have any of these things
that are holding me back like arthur
harrow was or like mark and stephen are
like i don't have that so how are you
gonna break me down enough for you to
take over my mind so i think it's gonna
be super he's gonna have to kill mark or
steven to get into layla's mind um yeah
keep going that's a really good give me
plenty i love that you brought that up
because like cause no because we see in
the end
i know i really do like that you brought
that up because arthur harrow does say
that like did can't you choose you
because you were broken already because
like maybe because like he was because
he has this like already pre-existing
condition like not to say that mark is
broken but like you know
i think it's easier for conscious to be
like all right this man has a very
fragmented mind so i'm going to sneak my
way in here and just be one more
yes
i was more vulnerable at that point like
you take that scene is actually a really
great indicator because uh that
conversation he has you know with ethan
hawk you know he's pretty much telling
him you know that he either made you
broken because he's a part of you or he
was a part of you because you're already
broken and then we get that scene later
down the road where
uh steven can't summon the suit and
layla is just like it's okay it's all
right like he's freaking out steven's
just losing it and leila's like okay
it's fine we'll find another way and i
think that's the great juxtaposition of
the two different minds on opposite
sides of the spectrum that you know show
why kanshu has hold of stephen and mark
and so forth and why layla is just so
far off out of his reach that he needs
mark and stephen to break her like you
were saying to reach her
maybe his ultimate goal maybe that is
his ultimate goal at the end of all this
maybe he just doesn't he doesn't want uh
stephen and mark he actually is using
stephen and mark to break layla because
layla is the ultimate moon knight that
he knows can be the ultimate you know
avatar for konchu
so
sounds like points
it seems like all the points to jess
all right i'm gonna give jess
i i'm gonna give just five thousand i'm
gonna give everybody five thousand
because these are all these are pretty
decent ideas though these are all decent
ideas
and i don't like giving people points
because i don't know i'm too nice
anybody's going in anyway let's move on
to our rogue question you guys ready for
this because this is gonna be worth one
million points and it will determine the
winner because that's how i roll
no that is true here we go here we go um
sam remy was asked this week about the
possibility of directing a spider-man 4
film with tobey maguire and didn't
completely dismiss the idea he didn't
dismiss it so pitch me your rogus idea
for a spider-man 4 with a middle-aged
peter parker man what do you guys think
a bunch of sad theories
uh
i'm just gonna get sad are you sure
do you want to know what i did today
mcguire has sciatica now yeah you
robbers stay here because i gotta go to
the bathroom real quick yeah
my doctor's uh fingers got stuck during
the prostate exam it was very
embarrassing
[Laughter]
all over the place like oh back rub feet
rub every bomb yeah uh he and mj have to
schedule their sex nights
during the week now they have scheduled
sex
where their marriage counselor
recommended that they they specifically
set aside time for intimacy
so they have a calendar
and uh on the calendar it says tax day
every time
that's like
yeah there you go marriage tax uh i
guess
yeah exactly i guess we'll you know do
the deed
a middle-aged peter parker oh god
i feel like he's a bmw but it's not what
he expected it doesn't make him feel
alive like he wanted it to well i don't
think okay so this is the thing i don't
think i think toby mcguire would have a
kid i think actual peter parker probably
wouldn't out of the fear of like
his identity the last thing he wants to
lose because he's already lost
is his child
so why would he bring something like
that into the world
um of like especially their world where
it's like he's the number one enemy to
all villains so it's like oh i can just
put this on like
i can retire from being a superhero it's
like no villains are still going to want
to kill you especially if they find out
who you are so we're hoping there's like
a miles morales in that zone that can
like take the manistle or the pedestal
um
i think realistically he would probably
be like a teacher
i think he would be a teacher at the
school he was once at and he would find
kids with other superpowers eventually
not like he would go out of his way but
one day there would be a student that
has a superpower and he'd be like you
have to like own it don't hide it don't
do this and then that they have like
their little buddy together moment and
he's like i'm actually spider-man so i
and they're like what you're spider-man
i just lift things with my mind and it's
like well we both
are super heroes and smart so
be okay with yourself i think that would
be like the route of what we'd see him
i i feel like that would be really fun
with like
everything that sam raimi has done
prior to even the the spider-man movies
everything that he's done prior to that
all his work and horror and comedy and
everything i feel like
because i know we may have one coming up
with this particular character but i
feel like sam raimi would be the perfect
director to do craven's last hunt
with mcguire my god spiderman so amazing
oh my god yeah because that horror
element would be perfect yeah every
aspect of that with the guy that's in
the sewers and then the whole bearing of
peter parker and i think we're at a
place in peter parker's life with tobey
maguire where
the contemplations of his life's past
events and things like that would really
weigh heavily while going through
everything um and then of course
obviously sam raimi can't do
everything he would love to do so
obviously it has to end the way you know
raven's last hunt ends uh i'm not gonna
spoil it for you if you haven't read it
go check it out um but everything's fine
everything's great everything's fine
everybody's sitting down eating crumpets
and teeth um
i i feel like sam raimi would be the
perfect director to pull that off just
because one of what we've seen with him
and his love for comic books and like
almost proper comic book adaptations
with the paneling and everything it
would just seem like the best fit yeah i
think that'd be honestly the way to go
because craven is a scary person to have
on your tail like he's a very he's a
huge threat for spider-man and so have a
horror director sort of guide that
through one of the best spider-mans on
screen like everyone's favorite
spider-man just being hunted down i love
that [ __ ]
all about that [ __ ] not to mention the
creature that's in the sewers that's in
the like this the b plot for that entire
comic book which spider-man and him are
having fights that's how craven is able
to capture spider-man because after that
battle and he's already beaten and
bloodied and everything and
it's it's a great comic it's a great
graphic novel yes check it out if you
haven't mm-hmm but what you got whitney
bring us home i want to see
spider-man as peter parker but obviously
toby mcguire but in this universe
peter parker is best friends with
leonardo dicaprio stay with me they do
the whole [ __ ] posse thing so it's
called spiderman oh my
and then i was like oh god they're
stupid little gang
they're stupid they're gonna have a boat
that they go on together they're gonna
have a yacht
uh leo's gonna talk toby into uh doing
like a whole great gatsby vibe thing
with his spiderman at some point
technically toby mcguire was in the
great gatsby he was i know right yeah
absolutely and i think that it's uh it's
gonna be his new era
you know what i'm all about i'm all for
a pus pot pete um
because there is of course a marvel
character named pace pop pete so that's
yeah that's amazing character
i would love to see that mr recreate the
great gatsby why not i just wanted to
recreate it that's how i there you go
but no uh but these are all very rogue
rogue very wrong theories but of course
i gotta give this to eddie for his idea
for craven because i i just need to see
craven hunt down a spider-man at one
point and possibly just stab him at
least once at least once yeah one time
and everybody i don't like the evil dead
that would be great like just all those
elements that he pulls from like evil
that or even evil dead too yes into this
movie that would be just perfect so
peter like just got stabbed though you
guys he did get started
again i love killing peter parker
a 40 year old man over and over and over
again listen i recently rewatched that
original raimi trilogy i do not like the
way that peter talks to to mj he was a
terrible boyfriend so he deserves worst
boyfriend worst boyfriend in the world
so two stabs minimum
there you go
but that makes eddie our winner for
today's rogue theory
but everyone of course is the winner
because you guys are all smart and
wonderful winners and jesus
but anyway that is it for this episode
of rogue theory of course i want to
thank our wonderful amazing
stupendous guests jessica clemons
whitney van lenningham and eddie linueva
support them wherever they are and of
course support our channel by checking
out all of our awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and do not forget
to pick up our new moonlight shirt it is
the dopest shirt ever and if you have
your own rogue theories you can share
them on our discord just make sure you
are over 18 when you join just click the
link in the description to bring you
right on there and follow me on
entertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] and follow the
rockstars on all of our social platforms
and be sure to subscribe to our channel
here on youtube thank you guys so much
for watching we love you guys so so much
and we'll see you guys next time goodbye
juice
our
deuces
deuces oh oh are we doing a dmx ending
yeah
facts going this time
[Music]
you